last time I was invited to Gary's house
it was a disaster all I did was have a
michelin-rated chef cook for yet it was
a night live only to be there that's
true and then we're sitting around an
hour before I slammed the door cos it
was freezing in your [ __ ] house did
you know the people outside were I just
know it was cold people probably
freezing to probably a completely
oblivious speaking of making yourself at
home this is a disaster I'm in his
office looking at all this equipment for
like hours waiting to eat I just want to
[ __ ] eat
ability to read the room like like hey
we just traveled from Long Island to
Connecticut it's a [ __ ] schlep and now
it's like it's getting late and we
haven't eat anything then you ate yeah
and you wanted to leave and Mary had
made all these special dessert Mary was
taking her sweet time serving I mean
it's like well we've eaten the main
course you know what I can I can I keep
hearing about dessert and it's not
coming I'm going right now to fortuned
for Howard to leave early and for Robin
and not coming on that's why I said
don't invite but am I gonna in this
Court Ted I felt like I was on the deck
of the Titanic no and it's funny because
one of the guys the guy in the court the
way this whole thing came about it was
an auction in my neighborhood so one of
the guys in the quartet it's one of the
dads and after that we kind of never
really you didn't do anything wrong I do
I think you didn't realize it was cold
in your house but you thought it was but
why not bring the koi ten inside if you
want everybody here oddly I think we put
them outside so they wouldn't annoy you
yeah well
[Laughter]